[Musique]
nombre de questions pierre jouyet de la
portée de plus la campagne électorale
dans louis hébert à québec a repris ses
sens après une série de controverses
mais un contexte particulier est apparu
avec l'arrivée de la nouvelle candidate
de la cac
geneviève guilbeault l'ancien porte
parole du bureau du coroner attend un
bébé pour décembre mais j'apprenais que
certains de mes adversaires tentent de
dissuader les gens de louis-hébert de
voter pour moi en prétextant que je suis
enceinte lors de ce débat télévisé
geneviève guilbaud s'était dite surprise
qu'on peut s'utiliser sa grossesse
contre elle et quand on a demandé à ses
adversaires de réagir bas et semblaient
tout aussi surpris moi je regarde je
pense 12 ans sur le terrain par jour
c'est quelque chose qui est très très
exigeant conséquemment je lui lève mon
chapeau
moi je suis une mère de famille j'ai
deux enfants j'étais en fait il ne m'a
jamais empêchée de travailler
moi je vois pas c'est quoi le problème
il ya des gens qui me parlent de ma
grossesse en disant vous êtes courageuse
mais c'est le fun à moi je profite mais
je dirais je
j'utilise ma situation actuelle de
femmes enceintes qui se lance en
politique pour envoyer ce que j'essaie
d'être un message positif au parent d'un
petit peu ridicule parce qu'elle va être
en congé de maternité cette dame là
j'imagine qu'elle a le droit d'être en
congé de maternité comme tout le monde
tant mieux elle va comprendre les
réalités des jeunes familles un vol de
yves attablé que je me disais c'est ben
beau et je présente accouchent dans deux
mois je vais y prendre son congé
maternité
quand est ce que vous êtes leur jeu très
à l'aise d'aller vers hutier based et
posent souvent des questions parce que
c'est ce que les gens peuvent avoir
l'impression que je vais être élu partir
en congé jusqu'à prochaines élections
donc finalement ce combat et les chaises
et des boutons et en 2017 on a la chance
d'avoir un congé parental que l'un ou
l'autre des deux concepts conjoint peut
prendre dans mon cas ce sera l'homme il
ya eu quinze élections partielles depuis
2014 louis hébert est sans aucun doute
l'une de celles ayant suscité le plus de
surprises et rarement les candidats
ont-ils autant été scrutés à la loupe
[Musique]